tous
[Musique]
je tiendrai accroche toi non lâche
bottes
c'est dans des passes plus de tout c'est
très bien mais la joie que ce que tente
en tente ta chance et tu vois ton était
prévu c'est moi mettons fera alors mike
jones
tu vois tout était prévu chez moi qui ai
du tonton tu es mort maggio ce match
comme ça je suis mort aa oui oui ce qui
est tout à fait rien il est bon en photo
et dont il sait
sinon ils jouent pas en fait ce plateau
fait son temps
tapie a senti quelque chose rapidement
tu fermes ta gueule
alors on sans fin ou comme sur des
roulettes
[Musique]
un gilet pare balles ban un gilet
pare-balles de tête
[Musique]
je suis trop vieux pour ces conneries
dominique était clairement trop vieux
pour ces conneries sauté d'un pont en
espérant tomber sur un véhicule
utilitaire lancé à vive allure
c'est impossible parce qu'on n'est pas
dans un film world war hulk l'écrit mais
françois lizeaux sbm d'accès pour
terminer l'entraînement qu'on se disait
il faudrait peut-être faire un truc type
slide rôle c'est un kiff de comédiens
devaient plein de comm univers
différents amen